as respiratory illnesses are spreading
the growing demand for medications or
leading to bare shelves around the
valley Mary Jane beliesza joins us in
studio with what's likely missing at
your neighborhood store
well we're not just seeing a shortage on
medicine but also other products like
canned goods and even tissues
when Karina blinks two young children
became sick this Christmas she made a
stop at the pharmacy to pick up some
medications only to find empty shelves
just the stress of trying to find
something even ordering online it's just
not available so you know when you find
a you know a Tylenol or anything you
just kind of grab it because you just
it's
yeah it's just not available
have aluminum Dr Jim Andrus director of
pediatric Critical Care in Summerlin
says he's seen a heavy winter virus
season which started much earlier this
year like any other viral illness all
these are accompanied with fevers and
and cough and runny nose and things like
that so lots of the products uh that are
normally on the shelves or get taken up
really quickly Dr Andrew says it's
important to stay on top of good hygiene
practices too and also we still haven't
even seen a big influx of of influenza
yet we're just starting to see it
again wachter says this is not a
medicine manufacturing problem and many
are getting sick at this time there are
medicines out there you just have to
shop around